these parts are indistinguishable mass
products that is until a laser engraves
a code on them giving each part a label
and identity that will determine its
path through the production process will
accompany an injector on its journey
through the Bosch Factory finally it
will fulfill its purpose to spray diesel
fuel into a truck engine they inject
within the injectors unambiguous number
now clearly identifies it wherever it is
the injector does not carry any
additional information with it but its
number connects it with the information
in the computer systems and this ensures
that wherever I spot this injector I can
access all the information on it that I
need for my tow industry into him / / -
Connie as assembly continues the
injector and others like it are
automatically kept under constant
control also by means of a high-speed
camera vast amounts of data are
constantly traveling through the factory
this is a zero defect system mistakes
are recognized immediately and corrected
but how stable is a system that depends
on so much data for my number i scans
are in my area we have very few problems
it's no secret that we average fewer
than two server crashes per year
Veta guides twice to one serve up
streets or Yahveh hop hop almost all the
data about the injector can also be
accessed through the internet that makes
bosch vulnerable to industrial espionage
for example a competitor could learn how
many parts a particular customer has
ordered
I'm businesses element an essential
element is that we as Bosch administer
our data independently and under our
control this ensures that no outsider
can access this data unless we have a
corresponding agreement with India
nation to find bubbling up radio signals
automatically keep track of which
injectors are completed and ready for
shipping the factories entire logistic
system is steered by radio that makes it
easier to get an overall picture of the
flow of wares and thus reduce warehouse
stock by 30 percent
machines and products are increasingly
communicating among themselves without
people so will the human worker become
superfluous when technology can organize
itself in the world of Industry version
4.0 context for industry to community
context to industry 4.0 people will find
new tasks there'll be people creating
the rules for the machines so that they
are able to communicate in the first
place and these will be highly qualified
tasks and we'll still need employees to
carry out activities that are complex
and cannot be carried out by machines
guitar by Dena Biden he can now Jesus
tool from the Bosch Factory in Hamburg
in southwestern Germany the injectors
are sent to the customers for example to
the car manufacturer daimler-benz where
the injectors also exchange information
with other machines
if even once the couldn't we deliver our
products to our customers and they use
them in their manufacturing process this
assembly generates an automatic signal
that we receive through the internet and
then we know what parts to produce that
tells the bosch factory precisely what
parts are necessary to fill the
customer's needs and a new injector with
a unique identity begins its journey
Oh